Over the last few years, Fox Business host
Maria Bartiromo has become increasingly
sycophantic when it comes to Donald Trump.
Each interview she gives him is easier and easier.
Never questioning his ludicrous and outrageous
ideas and his claims. And we have another
interview with her from this weekend. And it
couldn't have gone worse. And what's very funny
to see is that although her interviews get easier
and easier for Trump, Trump figures out a way to
do even more poorly. Regardless of how easy
the interview is, Donald Trump seems both to
have recovered from Corona virus and be sicker
than ever in a certain way. We're going to go
through this one and really think about what it
means for our country that this is the president
of the United States. Trump kicking things off
with the most powerful topic you can imagine.
Trump urges the media to cover the fact that Joe
Biden coughed the day before. Take a look at this.
I really don't. I don't believe it. And speaking
about Joe Biden. If you look at Joe, he was
coughing yesterday horribly and grabbing his mask
as he's coughing and speaking and grabbing his
mask and coughing. And I don't know what that was
all about. And it didn't get much press because
the press doesn't do that. But he was coughing
yesterday quite badly. I must tell you, and
it was not a good thing to watch. And and as
he's scoffing, he's grabbing his mask with his
fingers. So you may want to look into that, too.
So that's that. Right. A very, very powerful
critique of Joe Biden. Trump asked about the
Florida rally from last night. Maria Bartiromo
knowing that Trump plan to do a rally last
night, which he did, which we'll cover later
saying, what are you going to do to keep
people safe from Corona virus at your rally?
And Trump answers merely by talking about himself.
Look, I want you to answer your critics because
your critics are going really getting upset
about your event at the White House yesterday,
about your rally that you're planning tomorrow.
They say it is still too soon for you to be
around people and to be going out, that you
could still spread covered. What are you
doing in terms of ensuring that everyone will be
safe at your rally in Florida this week? Tomorrow.
Well, the doctors, the White House doctors, as
you know, are the best. And they said totally free
of spreading. There's no spread. And it wasn't
yesterday either. And by the way, I don't know
if you noticed I was on a balcony. The closest
person was probably a couple of hundred feet away
and they were down on grass. There
was nobody even close to me yesterday.
But even yesterday, I knew I was free.
What will you do to keep people safe? I
have great doctors. I'm not going to spread
this thing. And Trump doesn't even. He's so
narcissistically delusional that he doesn't
seem to get the concern. Isn't just. Are you
going to give the virus to someone? It's you're
packing people together with very few masks
and they're going to give it to each other. It
doesn't even enter into Trump's way of thinking.
Trump then claims to have a protective
glow now that he has had corona virus.
I passed the highest test to higher standards
and I'm in great shape. And I have to tell you,
I feel fantastically. I really feel good.
And I even feel good by the fact that,
you know, the word immunity means something.
Having having a really a protective glow
means something. I think it's very important to
have that to have that is a very important thing.
Trump's just radioactive from the virus. Ladies
and gentlemen, Trump then tried to talk policy.
This is where you really see how Trump's
cognition is suffering. It has declined. He
is completely unable to talk about policy.
Trump just wildly says as soon as we win,
everybody gets a middle income tax cut.
But at this point, does anybody believe it?
Can people we're giving a middle income tax cut
very soon. As soon as we win. We're giving a
middle income tax cut. It'll be a very substantial
middle income tax cut. And I've already done this.
As soon as I win, I give out a tax cut. Well,
why do you need to win? Why not do it now? Or
why didn't you already do it? Well, I've already
done it. Wait, so if you've already done it,
why are you doing it again? Incoherent.
No detail, just like I must remind you.
In August, Donald Trump was interviewed by Chris
Wallace in that interview. Donald Trump said In
two weeks we are signing a new health care system
into law. That was in early August. Two weeks have
come and gone. Four weeks have come and gone.
Eight weeks have now come and gone. Whatever
happened to that health care bill? We don't know.
Trump then again, completely unable to answer
this question. He's now gotten four, five, six
times. What is your agenda for the second term?
The answer? It's beyond parody. You can't
satirize the answer because there is no answer.
Back in February. What do you want to do in
terms of your policies in a second term, sir?
Well, the first thing we have to do is open up our
country. You can't keep all these seats closed up,
the Democrat states and they're not doing well
and the country is doing well. We're looking like
a super V.. But, you know, despite the fact New
York has to open up New York's like a ghost town,
New York is very sad what's going on there and
and other places. We just want a case in Michigan
against the governor, the governor that is,
you know, I call the complainer in chief.
All she does is complain except when she's
on the phone directly. All she does is say
thank you very much for doing such a great job.
What's your platform for the second term? Open
the country during a pandemic. Everything's great,
though. But Democrats are bad. New York is sad.
Michigan is bad. Wait, so what? What's
your second term policy? I'm confused.
There is none. Ladies and gentlemen, then in
the middle of the interview, it's almost a non
sequitur. It gets weird. Maria Bartiromo asks
Donald Trump. Are there you are foes. Trump
again, it's beyond parody. Trump says he's
going to look into that very strongly.
Take a look at this. This president, as
we wrap up here, are there UFO folks?
Well, I'm going to have to check on that. I
mean, I've heard that I heard that two days ago,
so I'll check on that. I'll take a good, strong
look at that. But I will tell you this. We now
have created a military the likes of which we've
never had before in terms of equipment, the
equipment that we have, the weapons that we have.
Trump's going to take a good strong Ahadi look
at whether there are UFOs. But what he is sure
of is he loves the military industrial complex
bragging about all the guns and weapons that he's
purchased. And then to close out the interview to
rounded out the president calls the FBI scum.
And Maria Bartiromo says, OK, as he's trying to
wrap up the interview and the FBI looked at
greatest people in the world or in the FBI,
but the top people were scum, absolute scum.
And they did a horrible job for our country.
Mr. President, we so appreciate your time
this morning. Thank you very much, sir.
President Donald J. Trump.
The FBI are scum. Thank you
so much for being here, Mr. President.
So the interviews get easier and easier.
These are supposed to be gotchas. I'm
sorry. Gimmes for Donald Trump. Just easy.
You know, like a two foot putt, which I don't
know if Trump can make a two foot putt. He
cheats at golf, too, but it's supposed to be
like the proverbial two foot putt. And Trump
just can't do it. He can't do it. And taking a
page out of his notebook is his son, Eric Trump,
who himself was interviewed over the weekend.
And that's what I want to talk about next.